ok although your interpreter will come first all
your kind of introduction and wrap his
tickets
blood link search you divide the background
hi hi join the staff
so poor operation for the rhino's group the
south group of online marketing hey
exactly where base in eindhoven that
weirdest thing about  to mark direction jesus is
who has four had the tumor city and just
working for the online editions
so again from technology bite take a
product we dress up rap and d doe
creative links our for international
clients and then a mess about it did
ahab
so again factry  teams is hot in the dating
and i'm the flawless dating science
the team five years ago but we'll
service shiro team and there may be full
sentence ebi testing
and these two balls that participate no
those implementations or one and this x
packages
but  it's basically the conversion rate
optimization team nets do die baby
testing and that's why angst en ding
here
because you go via the great will
pewdiepie date a region from met d  ennis
van booking.com
construction beast statistics i'd like to
be testing and back then i'll be playing
around the little
bit busy statistics with it this story
lithwick him mee ok
hijack this baby testing see sitting
next on'y cel henry  curious om how to
use the testing and situated in access
the changes
this is sisters that you make and them
company pickles this ladder
tyrian discussion out there batavus uri
color is ok love is the sex free go to
change things that you're doing it a
business zo
first of all who doesn't know where they
may be test is any body
well where that ok well i think also quickly
to this site
the claim istria i listened bitez
meanwhile you for sarandon the vision in
your sec man is there wheel control
experiment and they ridiculous array of to
senor facts there is religion to see in
thing is a lot of a beauty to do in the online
world so
and so so it is to be
really easy
but if you the die file the more i see
whether you access  ss every
white sand red keep things going om it
's it's tricks
so bassleader for topix they the heat
discuss
is use and the best distribution al
interviews critters that's textile management
who have the multiball commercial
problem the continuous monitoring
parliament
hotel something about stopping rules
as  we that enthusiastic ok he learns all
the city stay from practice so he has
quite and all slides
zoom ebf too big floor sanders and menno
tie up with priez pour way of
groningen too slow
i would put a wedge inside ok first
star wit weiss it  so much fun to the
drive in the babies it's sad
the thing is mostly a total butterfree
can is approach of statistics
banned and nurses the order front of
beast statistics and as real
discussion gyan here maybe freak a
sad and busy and there will all  views
of water and is also love balls and
business stuff
the the ex series she mee dat martians
what is really really fun te deep dive
into wit en  habits the specifics okay
what is actually make sense and what snap
so it is wheat to show the difference
between two touch of statistics
wanted to show you this picture so be
business in reverence there is jesse
commercial drove wimps would good your
varieties me formation and in  viewster
bit to pro's even better decisions
and you see is nicely first agree
way is nicely begin zero lf er if
you use the free this approach using
normal distribution and then you
exclusion values ​​bos wil values ​​be those
euro
zo of for this can be true week  if you
can have conversion know the lodge is
where i have a sudden fanfare design of
the experiment zo this can be true
wright dat before i go
show-off the flying first prototype
shoot the life and little bit more
into blowing extreme use this normal
distribution
there is base lego macally by weather tattoo
the is the test i class
so to refresh' memory realy would a
theory in freak and testing tests x is
the central li  mitering
en so basically says that for any
simple that you t en so long mes des
ardennes too cool and independer
distribution too much for rival
the sample mini wants everything could förch
wrestle to it is amazing when
detail
degryse is there hung crisis so
this extreme  instead these layers the
flow this is you from deta all those
with series will be curve norms
distribution in the ghent and you can
see the reeleezee that puts over the lord so
okay so as long as the sea and
distribution something like that before bit it melted out for
a while  theo hope it becomes clear
management ok so i say no so a
janitor paid with so mulder plight
climate or did on it and and you can
all the sea
ok dead it solutions de bertha taken
distribution de her om as jack let the
cm already en josie  dat values ​​belowzero
is not really
she is your problem anymore of so
the difference only takes place in give
well you close to zero one so you learn
very little deta wat is close to to 11
z  o exfoliate dancy and each of his
humor between and standards to the better
so fusion so this mix your other so all
things where all creatures used a
better so muse that is actually met er
in practice with this form you can use
and then there's another great  things
beyond what is the bios in the most
calculation reeleezee so extreme bek and
the d's within their vast computers would
you do was want i know you just cup
calculate directly and linear regression
it you if it never formula
they also any color the  kon van de
intervals
and this is a good thing to stretch is
it xlii is your vision so
two it and sup stretches norms
distributions lucas is and no 100
distribution
so actually for is in fact owe 4
weekend right at the old do and that
comes idea  from the computer just write
down on paper is the dissolution first
and that hair fillers and poles ok this is
like the simple difference
of that chair and sampling of
distribution and you see this jack leasing
z  ou you can be peeled off lectures
already getting old
him introduce the computer and then the
most beautiful borders 10 may be on our between
class is the pi value and keep srx lee then
and the final coz would you test the
spectator
so this is true that  the criticism sar
quickcool builds up is the holtinge heat
appliance you test for my richard
succumbs there is nothing sometimes and slimmer
geostar the test and use of korzel called
ortwin you have not can you will
that is can go wow so youtube you your
shirt correctly for  just with you as in
face like the factories and realize you
also find what it is same time this
mixta freely complicated ecoservice
europe at is the atmosphere die ok trickshot
your culture euro en a bit a
kind die caesar ok me mobility this is
the die effect  is I tell you I want to
zero' the so index is so keep you
step so yes so this is in the us so
in practice mixing it could you give
a lot of people bad and wanting a really
cause the stress is that  this is in the leather
of the white de holtinck ok like the she you
a shoot who has you to style it
what axiom practice the oil dare and
series that i have 11a you know hit your
ski lift in the level
the use half of the first place  and the
view the calculations is basily so the one
in which you or gesture' toe and is only the
white strange our from your business
perspective
if you choose and sing live is level 11
a and the role that guy with iwan with danny
jarges de the fish me  how can this
be such roll but about the solid
stress that doing business is the of the
new science
sciences your phones then okay who her
pots size ittersum
effect who collect data it who our
team who is all the way that's papers
so you once control  the pressure is worth
publishing parsley mitts control how
many papers
hp switch has can you will oats in
business you be much more focused to
vanilla what you by noah minuscule and for
sale that test in bugfix that you an
over sure that is  going to better a
new a mirrors this is not
interesting to research the first place
zo you guys want to find out things you
don't know and
front  and only be able to passion
paper of you who
show des antiquaires
so double question for you so want ep
testing
a passion you find groningen
test for quite some time en it the
tests romanian insignificant
so making your ex lead goal from but
die  your good food and what they would be
doing
m
yes this is who said to
we are looking for little bit more practical
ansermet de kitchen sorry for that
yes so things like this acquire more
details she is something that's winan in
practice and then ever take some time  on
what you how it yay okay you if
so I think okay anyway so I also want
item girl with what do you need
this guy directions so that you also have a
second caution here is the fold in the  us
what what do you push the private sphere even
liquid that feels or what do you want to be
implementing
that they ferry this so would the fortress is your
jury member never be testing or is a
telephone nipkens
beagles if i ever riche nice effect it
can take forever to  to finance more
you will find so in that not for
business perspective this is another
cool thing to do with what have they in
practice is how to stop manchu for
test and judo well maybe you have there you
will people rident to stick to the
the full  version and it is of course in
zwolle of practical tips in r ok that's
so in people als to program the new
fried translate the engine your specialist is
simple the confused new for eines
already there and exceed is another
cool thing to do for you  business week
if you can you see is baie scans die
furnishing lif can you so wiki the
die feels with first test x is no reason
at role where to find shoeby die full
so it takes the cm effort you should
actually implementin  g the best ryan
expectation there now base
although you don't have we see
can wiesel
so let's go to the base insights by the
best distribution so
deny stinkwater better so fusion is abby
test is vol loos de
bernoulli distribution and by definition
the best  discussion is the distribution of
the
the beeper amateur
in so this business or this is not like
a text message not the kind of thing would
want it fedele the alderman asian way of
working
works and you already ain't the tribes the
prior with the boutique mitch  on prior sweet
and your updates you please
by collection moore acted like
depicting them another set is flying
zealand you so the
the the priors between bed against that
I chose an influence your results by
choosing prior this is early bed what
animal use  people use to do is
get a prior this is an informative sauce
novilon floor insinger you will be like me
simple
newstar we wind the test you prior ruby
betta where man and you can see it
superflat so this is not l  ike
wheelie gig more value to to one side or
another and then you kollektion theta and
the first nothing about the beds so
fusion you can update the program so
derek sweet to your detail sorry don't
have them by estimation you can so also
the star  this here and then you here now
distribution and the only next i see this
is like the bang be auto prior in
white prions you here see the there quite
quiet is one
and the all he who of vision updating is
because shaft length de date a you  can use
their desire
and you know by a viper on this
physical nice but did it again this
like the preview will
that leaked summer did her and you can
see what we do here
this is me you would not a fat tire
your sicily motor de  lift and the pass
you this music
so you keep gram is sometimes in you with fien
boot and the
dit narrower so the conversion interval in
greek test for how narrower thick
if you dance a little more this is how
your comfort is interval is kelly's
moulijn  smother with what I  could seller
is intervals is a chip shop is to rush
and busy in this scholte
lubberink whatever sides the yes so deny
sting about a robot distribution is
you can there is a soup could you can
easily chalice suffered is better so fusion you
know took it in  factory will of the
defense of je effect is in fact norberta
distribution however since computers
again phaeton
week and risoli t samples of those
distributions and with that can calculate
the defense distribution and this allows
a piece of the promobility
share here effe positive effect
they had the questions  dewey catching
difference in
we have friends who have chair approaches
so again pot boat and so
let previous slide en johan and tess
you can see the light
exec lian top of each other zo this give
you a picture by the practice of to do
here of  research single
comes a relay bitez do you catch the
fresh must see now are the beds and their
eyes distribution he served finance
single knees were textile  you will
win this point business decisions and
even if it is the pier valley is slightly
different than it no's mars and snapped
do your hobby effort or do a little
analysis
you hit that your prix value and leaf is
a risk school for reject a huge
sperm whale is den joss stone do you do it in
texel lewitt longer
ok would reveal i stop i stop the
multiball commercial stage
yes so realy toe and practice the
official just having to science bed in
a country of case you would want to the
more new ryan's
testing borders  it feels like this will
be colton ebn test how the song for
eyes becomes like this is the problem here if you
increase in orange scenes it is too
dead ceiling hear and become spin then
in doom practice
is also a poodle through science
life' and three  testing and theory find one
of more times to be significantly better
than other and then be just pick the
best ryan en be implemented by what is
a little bit random write zo you first
star testing en  you don't look at your
day terry moore
if you want to know whether you're
changes using is in fact
they display the the tools the best ryan
so what you do heat focus more
to the confusing the six pack to the best
and  do i it is it is me for this
confusing i was what you live and
official is whether the changes you
want to implement is actually now
from clean better than i live for ipad you
practice s3
awhile so the cake
maybe you wanted jobs a lot  for ryan's
with stil continue testing
wit toe if i new ryan's that might
still be time for the first place
so second lesson know where you de mulder
polkamp there is a problem
sister problem he this is dylan
simulation where you can the free anyway
is where  your finger out of her pot is
is is that is exactly the same for about
ryan's
would he picks beeper a matter if it's your
patient
it's the lyceum for our my then
you what's okay so i'm telling you a
case
so anybody  does these tests who can per
role  de deventer sales a budget
how many times armrests concluded
that chinese art does infect oil
if so do you have a white or how do
you read down and what you sequence mr
this nonsense wooden to your 211 vario
toe elven
as the vals discovery knows  that your ex
sweet idols i can't you will
without any difference in fact being in
the parameters like you can see if i go
to
van toot toot san fransisco juice be
quickly it's already so they were had x
discussion as their member sherlock i looked
keep you correct compaction I as the
alpha most cm ivory feel that
you're wrong
were you or too in view follow richard
rocks
thanks throw loose this in business is
likely to be not pass bed is so serious
that is what you have for the  bass and ruby ​​c are
in reality are ever the case that the
that keeps nora pad is is is true
zo is a bucket the case is your wheel i
truly like in the smal is that telex
jackie so a reverse and be ahead of
you  ian's so medical work  den ting
toe
sample little bit in beeping routers
in conversion rates or there for ian's it
and xlii checks okay what harry
picking she cut I people not right
for island'
look looking at performatory simple so
what you say you're ready is that so  'n
your move murder was on ansar the test
beer like this where you
live f-series in that's what you care
water in the business
back in all religions each this country
lower what quiet this is
i erase in quite van mirrors of course
if you  get more more for ian's and you
can there of the four rise against each
other than you get
lydia land kan berns that you join you from
hype mobility or beer around without
well what your wheel i care about and
practice is ok the porch shed
blood  life is the in fact the trump cards ryan
this is is performing best so is it
before what je who want to be looking it
's ok so best for ian's is this for
right thing ever the better than your
eyes and nephew en used a part of  the
test I have an explicit that
be back soon that's a kiss
yes yes yes yes this would you what do you mean this
is so a simulation right would rather like
her so yes he became we
too tight would we this is jesse their
station midas yes i see two out  drink
and that this deep and probe two effect
your big file in the details download
cool effect so with your hearts the
foil
calculate is false discovery girl on i
like this if you milete did art
this death note this just rough
give nelis party so  it clarify te
wit yes oh shoot
the dare en is between a better this
shows in cheating as the commercial race
and even
earth sublim is in the best diffusion
and then you want to know inhabitants
perform better
would you want to calculate wat de root a
place  to be for
hot verizon and she would be a shame so why
you want and also any suffering for is in
michigan difference in jopie valley and
the pier value star boat coming from my
bed it's fusion and then right season
3 but the difference bet  ween those two
yes ok so it is led wit of using the
value
de paypal correct program er of your by
urban elite er solution
so that the pier value you do this
freak en de muscle value
something like arwout is calculating the is de
propos billet i  did you even positive
effect
yes ok drinks
yes you could see it is already for
the choir that van picture
evy olie mantel ok arry xlii in the mens
entrance for ian's and this is much a lower
than
pearly of useful radical types of
food best grating in  beast
statistics you can xlii
use to further reviews the popo buttocks
tee of
or a measurement that servers pico's gf02
comparisons cools your arkel base
he must learn code fire on fourthly
that of details in the bow at the waist
agent go too much and today  title wat
he die is that you already showroom that all
your eyes at the same distribution and
of there you collect evidence in your collective labor agreement
maybe there will be different
and what xlii have his practice is if
you can zi  and there so this would be wit and
we the old hierarchy
and you can see the grams wit small
the blood sorrow white shark ok i in
ex-lease songs will tight
it's coach shrinkage the hair coming
closer to each other and is we to
system i was it is the pencil number
of times as a running and door for
angers the stronger the springers is
and yes this is there an argument or a
correction for faulty jerk om email
of er onions and you still want him
distributions that you cool
cando analysis on and expectation that then
the aged in reuver sitting
touting you this is where the
green kitchen explicitly orange to
feel about the direct to its ultimate
comparison
so that we be something interesting to
research and as you can see down
this is for  eyes whitmore samples and
they connection' dat
green-kids is jenny les in a storm so
the moral instagram de les grandes
boyfriend is which makes sense peaks
chef more evidence to actually
c that you insect have this  point who will be
for something or you for riot
ok so i think right to speed up a
little bit
yes so you can monitoring is another
problem like the polymer
actually in the cws want over rises
containment
your voice discovery reed
this is already salt floor or  you look at to
date in between so form shoot
firth with your moodle cover did a look
at the details see where you might live from
them idonotes winter you will
west here while your date keeps you
know use it anymore but in practice this
is really  not getting to do
because you want to look at the detail
that can find seville music in
orange ones who this live I as in
fact you know perform better solution
sales walnut implementing is surprisingly
first in a secondary charming you
can here what you  test now
just dancer on said you want to continue
what you are testing now and season in the track
a bossche bol deliver attentive
target who they look intense from the did
on because it is significant and  he step
in and this again even a by step in
times it's crucial party
why this is the chain here you can see
how it s will be people so this light
de the differnz here in fact and debit
scanning narrow smother wind yengeese oh
this is  i came from like there would be
no effect site if you can risk
another day and if you look at one point in
time and actually is fibers and chance
that you will be getting is but the view
your cashier turns i any point and the
try  they still detail that you will be
outside the counters I you over the
horizon you are you of all of points and
you have to build as a parent so that you
check in wise everywhere dvd toppoint
then you much more likely to bosnia we
have jack too 0 broken seat  in me jack
zo and you on the corn the saying this is
like two for sets the treaty
patient of the cases and then doubting the
lil [ __ ] because there's a slice staff
in this one it's x value actions
show ok fix the us topping  roel ottow
rather show qinet  iq indifference
with all such a stop in roel for ok well
come again so that the testable in sync
with you will
den the tension is kindness of in
self shops in view pickets deta and
dazzle sorry are where to stop
research then this actually  do
you feel like a wet skate in
your full discovery rode and the user with it
cools the region of effects korey kuhl
once you know live there go into the tail
you are in pointe is here that if
you see in practice
how many transtar  exilis i don't know
dewi wife clowns your finder old
dirty percent so seasons offers so
cruel have out about this great
inflation by can you now monitoring' this
is real somebody fury
stopping murder extra darn cincinnati
knows a problem don't have wheelie gig
bottom however  it's wheelie
depending on how to this thing for
chantal reviews to early and look and
dating rvd what you can fix your oil start-stop for
insight will fix did the
you did so this one worked  at night and
basically a lifetime straight from the hood
simple de mortar conclusions in
expert people not ok i know this
region of practical i again and sexy be a
good stop in real to use and practice ze
xperia v the hardline ok now it
stops  the test arouse you
insignificant so you forcing business
to work an old city with move on to the
next rest and with which i say found between
this reason of practical equivalence
was quite scripting do i get your
selection aiming to proof and practical
equivalent would you apologize  still waiting
too long both working more more it
is xlii checking okay translating
we will equally kind and wheat that you because they
do over here and this test is gone too
slow the judo pull bacon to find a big
enough h-blast
to be able to  reach a target then that
should be the case of
buyer  est to be able to get to recharge
work atmosphere vines also the cashier like
want to know for vision or presses
i stick you equivalent how is xlii termine what
practical is you lame and sith and this such a
thing who to do her for business
mirrors is so app store  act like ok
windows dewey not care about de défense
anymore
however if you as business ok now want
you to avatar the about here or what your
tink is violinist i de knowledge and uplift
then that is something i in xlii
disco's buddy better and desk studies
because in that you can work from ok sam
I now stop taking micros at a standstill
eye for questions
oh for there to the judgment of our
right
ok ok then on cloudy it the little
bit to slide
yes if
yes that the problem is that you  i see what
you wanted your
is compare something ryan can teach for
ian's so this is word becomes
literature discussing about so what your
goal is for this ryan chargers comparing
residential source and in fri 3 jan your day after
one white  de wang en de
maar met the other end and the other two
together' would this is getting bigger wgbo
but just tomorrow ryan's then you
ex lydia competitor so you mee
krenning much more much bigger
variance
of ryan's
sorry for mixing on the length but it
's  real killing science gymnasts in the
business turkish hitting houses killing
together you just so the
love you pecked best once light
expedition is your reference guide
so even though the case is gray so is not like
i
but you can just do the basic tee
test
between over aiies en een and your caterpie
value yes for a dress on oil of you
care about
ok who we know our know what the winner is
your canonical computer winner is this the
bike of course all the other for ian's
yes would this be beauty however  this
edition this what you do and practically
right you that you won't and also so
the best ryan or dol are and you
explicit the problem white need to
person is marshall essay veronica the
best confusing is jos e  I year what
also check in you want to compare something
fight against each other than you have
margin of portland white is
multi two a person's game any other
questions
yes that was the white so this is oil
banstead basically
and of course
who in for sale
this may be also is decay 5 jumping
between i hope my betty your brush
this santinge ride in the wheelie is
core white but even with some xlii copy
your intersym batmobile is confusing
xlii looking with your samples and times
in patient is of time's den de
change you meanwhile build is the
winner in your total samples
would this is it was want to know in front of the
door and a your children cliché ok what
is on mobile tee of this bruni jelte
with winner
yes i say you want yes o i say
museum to  you were just further in the
smart we gather in sweden der weerd
ok
in practice de the problem is that sbk
fuel tank at first and this could be
realized way of
or so they came back to the
hierarchy
zo so we b  y mc is a very very great
fairy
width toe yes so best yes I had is from
the blog post you can we could manage
he ten times this finally stupid stabbing
to wrappers that was not
doing this was attendants do what you die
shirley get light  so even better
distribution and in your former herbie and
box highlighter parameters so quiet quiet
not to choose a lighter pryor and this is
the hype oh boy oh boy oh boy oh boy oh
boy oh my
the link is if we their the blog to
dereference and  the die is ok it is the
hardware pillar the mail is a
uniform t fiber paris you do not
influence in you
like i do in a minute what will you implied
is treasure
ok the the peak value the beeper amateurs
or for teachers ryan's in which the
beginning comes  i of scenes fusion
this piper pryor and tell you connect
more evidence it dx free to all the fun
rates and because they have the share
so a
say hi to prior this is how pretty the
drinkers
takes place i have if this is actually
the cause connect  to  say
parents prior day they come closer to
each other and only when those in this
real life balance is
de Waar fried have more detail then it to
be all out more to differ van light de
leverage offereins together yes yes so
looked more like you and shouldn  the
descriptive earthlite a piece of veluwe
contact
so for cember is kobe you ff a
homepage
oh sorry ok the question was i can you
describe a little more eldest should be
test in online marketing experts anyway
little bit more pics look like this
works for  jumpy has the homepage you
know because the tests new confusing or
your homepage and you don't yet get sex
cleaner taste through wet and this what
you want to find a and a correct move the
goal for sambal
earth ecommerce website so find sales
so mobile conversions  so what you do
you use the script
it is completely randomly a boring one
to die like ok this user is a
check with day and the others in segment
be
then you work hands any time any
lending then put the home page and how
many of the us and segment your site
and be and purchasing agent would this
will be this is hans wil je tassel
yes yes would be without user level and
of course a few minutes truly the semi
user this dit  is wie ik leer test
wil of course jef cookies with you larger devices and you know you door effects that xlii true
user group i in in beauté en b-segment
oat you it's a samsung net you do
n't make now
and zopie testing is you  realy flow
restore we or
person effect in comparison to
collecting detail and then try to
explain die off to true speckles and
all is now you meet the means
will influence in signo effect with
which bitez distillerie that clearway of
or losers in fact doe than for
true  you you will be given choose the yoko
oh sorry sorry sorry sorry sorry
hot wind do you feel
yes yes that I once
tasted a tipping she was an expression have sex in
the polder that dude out would your
keeper did  hair around your cake that
keeps different self there is what you don't have two
and for ein since' okay these ones
offshore wet winters and how youtube
so kicked maud and you can the you testing
i do things did you that forward
weenie yellow ryan
's  he what you don't
what do you know in that chair of width
yes
yes yes smile and
real a little higher when it
starts in all you me reviews dude and pod
and the viewer groningen 0 stuff
confusing s before then how would
really see why would be  do that you
locker might be more interesting in
went new brain testing minds
that feel the secondary
what you can you copy and exilis
another very bad guy that tough guys wanting
it's mature [ __ ] pushing practice
like so 1st testing to see whether the
hecho  process you bye
where i do your best to make to at cz
leadership and then don't tell the people
at the running the test en nancy were d
come so i can't you'll be so
to push the ruby ​​interesting peak a  ls sms
know test where the rain
when your good job there wet in the exactly
where you these tips tricks for course
to start a new test and ritesh that
states you in there more for
so is your praxis stores still no matter
how you  this stuff you still es la i
have mobile tee or eff as discovery of
course
so take it out you do you your goal
because we keep this week so so you're
taking time for testing and note
too much time rendition
first things first three superman  miracle
comfort
[Applause]